I probably have had an interest in cars
it's age 16 on-and-off various sports
cars got very involved with high
performance driving and racing it led me
to be enthused enough that I became an
instructor of that discipline for other
people I think any of us that do any
kind of performance driving learn you're
not trying to seeking thrills you're
just trying to minimize the possibility
of something going wrong
I was certainly familiar with Tesla but
knew nothing of any detail yes I could
understand the electric and believe it
was a very important part but that
didn't come first the car made measures
of performance beauty absolute utility
and with those all in mind I mean it
became very apparent that this this car
was something special I would say very
few people even give a moment's thought
to say I guess that's why we call them
accidents what's going on a familiar
street came to it familiar traffic light
at the point it turned green died went
ahead
life change I think if I have a
stopwatch the whole time period I'm
talking about would have been one third
of a second all the sudden it's this
bluish car coming in division our impact
was her front end of the car right
against my hip he's barely able to get
my door open and when I did I discovered
that car was so stiff I got off to the
side of the road on three wheels and
unfortunately she was hurt had to go to
the hospital but I had absolutely no
injury now I was extremely lucky but
part of that luck was being in the
safest car in the world
I think the biggest attitude adjustment
for me was no longer filtering my view
of cars from the point of view of the
performance and the handling and the
beauty and the things of that time
it really reordered to safety comes
ahead of everything else my name is Jim
Hartman and I survived a significant
crash in the Tesla Model S